. Podcast Ufo, Podcast, Podcast, Podcast, Podcast, Ufo, Podcast, Ufo, Podcast, Ufo, mit Florentin Will und Stefan Tietze. Völlig richtig, so heißen wir. Herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe von das Podcast Ufo dpu.dpu.org. Und Stefan Tietze ist dabei und Flo und Tim Will jetzt auch dabei. Wir freuen uns sehr, dass ihr wieder reingeschaut habt, reingeschneit seid und gesagt, reinschneiden sagt man noch im Sommer nicht, ne? Das ist ein Wort, das ist ein Wort für den Winter. Weißt du, was man im Sommer sagt? Ja, macht die Frische auf. Erfrischung, künstlich. Wohingegen im Winter macht man eher tiefe Geräusche. Gibt kein Wort dafür, ne? Kein Wort. Kann man nicht benennen. Wenn du das in Drehbuch schreibst, dann muss der Schauspieler gucken, wobei. Durchatmen. Naja, halt dieses Erfrischende, nachdem man was geschluckt hat. Ja, nachdem man was Wasser getrunken hat, mit Kohlensäure. Und es ordentlich zischt, was so Kondenswasser noch rechts runterlaufen hat. Aber es ist ein schönes, da fängt der Sommer an. Stell dir mal vor, du wirst in einer Welt leben, wo alles so aussieht wie Werbung, wo wirklich jede Flasche außen dieses perlende Kondenswasser hat, wo jeder Burger diese tollen ganzen Sesam-Kügelchen oben drauf hat. Wo immer noch teilweise die Zutaten daneben liegen, so ein bisschen zerst bisschen zerstreuen. Selbst der Burger bei McDonalds ist wunderschön angerichtet, wunderschön garniert. Das fände ich mal toll. Das fände ich richtig gut, aber ich glaube, es ist auch viel Druck, weil ich meine, du bist ausgebildeter Koch, du benutzt Verben wie Blanchieren oder Karamellisieren, also viel Ich benutze wirklich viele, viele, die man nicht so kennt und zuordnen kann. Wo man erst mal fragt, was machst du da genau beim Karamellisieren? Ja, im Prinzip Karamell, aber auch du musst doch wissen, dass hässliches Essen besser schmeckt. Auf gar keinen Fall. Naja, das ist eine Lüge. Ich habe mir jetzt, ich habe jetzt eine neue Masterclass, nachdem ich Aaron Sorkin, Werner Herzog, Shonda Rhimes, Tiger Woods und Serena Williams-Brieg mit Tennisbein.
Sehr vielseitiger Mensch.
Aber jetzt eigentlich die einzige Masterclass gemacht, die sinnvoll ist, die von Thomas Keller, die Koch-Masterclass.
Sehr gut.
Weil, muss man sagen, das macht richtig Sinn, in Echtzeit mit dem da rumzuköcheln. In Echtzeit geht das nicht viel zu schnell? Nee, wenn er jetzt, sagen wir mal, also so eine 15 Minuten ist ja im Schnitt so eine Lesson lang. Und dann ist halt eine Artischocke kochen mit Thomas Keller 15 Minuten. Ja, dauert in etwa 15 Minuten. Und dann habe ich mit ihm zusammen Möhren glasiert, Karotten, wahnsinnig toll, das kann man ganz einfach machen. Glasieren, guck mal, da haben wir es wieder. Glasieren ist einfach ganz toll, in der Pfanne schön ein paar Möhrchen reinschnibbeln, macht er speziell, ist aber echt auch ein bisschen egal, das ist übrigens mein großes Takeaway, ist auch so ein bisschen egal. Dann machst du Zucker drüber, so einen Esslöffel, dann die ganze Pfanne so schön, aber immer schön so ein bisschen Abstand zwischen den Möhren, dann ein bisschen Zucker drüber, dann Wasser auffüllen, dass es gerade diese Karotten bedeckt, dann lässt es einfach, dann kochst es runter, reduzierst, wie wir hier sagen, das Wasser, dann machst du noch ein bisschen Essig rein, damit die Aromen so ganz durchkommen und dann hast du sie glasiert und dann kommen die Zuckerstoffe so richtig schön durch. Und schon habt ihr, liebe Hörer, euch eine Masterclass gespart, denn Stefan Tietze ist ein Raubkopierer, er eignet sich das Wissen der Welt an und gibt es euch kostenlos, das ist strafbar. Weisst du, was ich mache? Ich mache einen YouTube-Channel auf, Stefan Tietze schaut Masterclass und ich gucke mir das immer an das Video auf Kopfhörer, pausiere und sage dann, was derjenige gesagt hat. Genau. Also Aaron Sorkin hat gerade gesagt, also auf Englisch, aber und da verrenne ich mich immer so ein bisschen, weil ich dann auch, man merkt nicht genau, wo schwingt jetzt meine eigene Meinung mit und wo hört Stefan Tietze auf, wo fängt Aaron Sorkin an, wobei das weiß man ja eh nicht so genau. Ja, das stimmt. Nee, ist eine gute Idee, Ideenklau, einfach du bist so ein Dieb, du brichst irgendwo ein, du gehst in ein Museum, triffst dann die Leute vor Museum, kauft euch kein Ticket, hier, ich beschreibe euch grob, wie es ist, riesiger, riesiger Knochenmann mit zwei Beinen, zwei kümmerlichen Armen und grauen Haaren. Grauen Haaren, gut. Der T-Rex hat graue Haare. Das lässt sich nicht los, aber es ist ein grosses Problem.
Es ist ein grosses Problem.
Ich habe diese Woche auch gekocht und ich weiss nicht, wie ich es schaffe, aber ich kriege es einfach hin, mein Essen regelmässig so zu ruinieren, dass ich es nicht essen kann. Wirklich, ich hatte Lust auf Apfelmove. Da fängt es schon an. Also wenn Google fragt, meinten sie, dann meintest du auch wahrscheinlich das. Wenn du ein gutes Rezept von Apfelmove gemacht hast, verstehe ich schon noch.
Ja, ich mach den Apfelmove, kennst du es nicht so, ich gehe in einen Club, die, die, die, wie sagt man, Frauen schauen mich an, und ich mach den Apfelmove und ich pflück den Apfel oben, ich pflück den Apfel unten, ich pflück den Apfel in der Mitte, ich beiß rein, was ist das ein Kern, was ist das ein Kern, ausspucken, am Kern verschluckt, ich hab mich am Kern verschluckt. Ja, das ist der Apfel-Move. Du nimm mal dieser prüfende Blick, also ich ess den Apfel immer so weit auf wie mein Nebenmann. Ich hab keinen Apfel-Es-Kodex in mir drin. Du hast keinen Apfel-Standard, du hast keinen Anspruch. Ihr habt keinen Apfelstandard,-Kodex in mir drin. Du hast keinen Anspruch. Du hast keinen Anspruch. Übrigens, das ist gut. Man kann Menschen gut einteilen in verschiedenen Schubladen. Zum Beispiel, was tragen sie für Klamotten, tragen sie Markenklamotten oder nicht. Man kann Menschen in so Schubladen einteilen. Wie weit sie den Apfel essen, ist ein guter Maßstab. Und wenn ihr beim ersten Date guckt, einfach die Person vor euch, wie weit ist ihr den Apfel. Gibt ihr einen Apfel oder ihm? Einfach so einen wortlosen Apfel vor die Person stellen und gucken wie die reagieren und dann je nachdem wie weit ihr den essen und das darf, es muss in so einer gewissen Zone in der Nähe sein zu eurem Apfelstandard, AS, weil zu weit ist nicht gut, weil ich zum Beispiel esse den kaum auf und dann ist er für mich schon gone. Nee, zwei, drei Bisse weg. So, wenn ich jetzt eine Person treffe, ich glaube nicht, dass ich mit einer Frau zusammen sein könnte, die den Apfel ganz isst. Nein, ganz ganz nicht. Und es gibt viele, die essen den ganz. Ja, aber so richtig ganz. War das nicht auch das Problem im Paradies, Adam und Eva mit dem Apfel, dass sie ihn nur halb gegessen haben und die Schlange meinte, ja Leute, so geht's nicht. Das wollte er alles wegwerfen, das ist alles noch Apfel. Das ist alles noch Apfel vom Baum der Weisheit. Leute, wie dumm kann man sein? Und Adam so, nee, aber ich will da jetzt nicht diesen Kern, da fuhlt er so einen Kern aus der Wacke und da so, hm. War der eigentlich richtig gut, dieser Apfel? Also das sind immer so diese Dinge, die in der Bibel nicht erwähnt werden, so das, worum es geht. Ja, ihr habt gesündigt, ja, ihr seid dafür aus dem Paradies geworfen worden, aber war es das wert? Pink Lady. Was ein Pink Lady, was ein Fruit Sensation, was war es, war es so ein schöner Bosskopp, was ist das, wo war das Paradies eigentlich, auch im Mittleren Osten? Man weiss es nicht genau. Was war das, wo das Paradies ist? Wo liegt das Paradies, also die Bibel spielt ja so im Nahen Osten und so. Gut, dass du fragst. Die Türkei, reise auch du in die Türkei. Und mit dem Code UFO30 bekommt ihr nichts. Müsst ihr draufzahlen, müsst ihr draufzahlen. Aber man weiß es ja gar nicht. Ich meine, die Leute, die damals die Bibel gelesen haben, die damals vor den Buchläden kampiert haben, drei Wochen lang, bis die Bibel rauskommt. Bis Bibel zwei erscheint. Neu Testament, wie geht's weiter? Was haben die unter Apfel verstanden damals? Weil so gibt's da eigentlich so im muss ich mal drüber lachen. Hier bei True Detective und so haben alle mal gesagt, wow, wie innovativ, neue Staffel, ganz neuer Cast, das ist schon krass die Idee. Bibel macht das seit 2000 Jahren.
Die geben Scheiss.
Ich meine, die zweite Staffel Bibel fing an mit zweieinhalbtausend Jahre später.
Und alle Fans so, what the fuck?
Was ist mit Ruth?
Ruth ist tot, Abraham ist tot, alle tot, alle weg.
Mehr Moses.
Ja, und dann so der klassische Wecker, Jesus schlägt auf den Wecker, so geht ihr eine gute Staffel los.
Ja, so muss es sein.
Also wer ist, who is this guy? I like his style, I like his vibe. Who is that guy? Ja, stimmt schon, aber ja, weiss man nicht genau. Aber Apfel ist tatsächlich ein interessantes Problem, weil ich bin ja mittlerweile übergegangen zum, ich bin kleiner. Zu Birne. Ne, ne, ne, ich bin Wohlfühl-Apfelgenießer, und zwar ich schneide ihn in Stücke. Mir macht das Spaß, ich schneide das in acht Teile, kratze das raus und dann habe ich so einen Teller, so eine kleine Mahlzeit mit acht Achteln vorgelegt. Ist auch ein bisschen was psychologisches, dass man sagt, der Apfel an sich sieht nicht aus wie eine Mahlzeit. Ihn zu schneiden, dass er einen Teller füllt, generell, wenn ihr abnehmen wollt, immer eine gute Idee, richtet die Dinge so an, dass sie aussehen, als würden sie einen Teller füllen. Ja, und du hast Liebe mit reingesteckt, du hast Arbeit reingesteckt, die kannst du dann gelesen. Liebe mit reingesteckt? Natürlich. Liebe? Beim Apfelschneiden hast du Liebe, empfindest du Liebe als Gefühl? Ja klar, das musst du schon sorgfältig machen, das kannst du nicht so mit halber hand machen dann schneidest du den finger hast du wenigstens glasiert na ja ein bisschen zucker
muss schon noch oben drauf wenn man damit mal anfängt kommt auch nicht mehr zurück aber man
kann ja in den garten gehen wenn man einen garten hat zum rhabarber stand wenn man hat und dann
kann man sich da so eine rhabarber rausreissen aus so eine Rhabarberstrauchpflanze, eine Borke, eine Rinde, eine Rinde, Rhabarberborke. Du kannst Rhabarber nehmen und du kannst Rhabarber einfach im Zucker, das haben wir im Kindergarten, haben wir es gemacht, Zucker war immer ein großes Tabuthema, Aber einmal im Jahr war grosse Rhabarberbernte und dann konnte man rausgehen zum Rhabarberbaum und dann konnte man mit der Barbara zum Rhabarberstrauch gehen, konnte schön Rhabarber nehmen, in den Zucker tunken und dann essen und es schmeckt fantastisch. Ja, kleiner Tipp da draußen, geht mal raus, greift in die Rhabarber, jeder hat eine Rhabarber zu Hause. Ist nicht wieder bald Rhabarberstandzeit? Das Lustigste, was ich letztens gesehen habe, war, dass jemand Spargel in so einer grossen Erdbeere verkauft hat. Ja, aber das passiert regelmäßig. Aber warum? Weil man will nicht ein phallusförmiges Gebäude haben. Erdbeere ist ein so der Stand. Aber dann mach einen Neutralenstand. Ich gehe auch nicht in einem Hotdog-Kostüm raus und sage Pizza, Pizza, wer will ein Stück Pizza? Das geht nicht. Das kannst du nicht machen. Aber ich, These, Erdbeeren sind nur so erfolgreich, weil die Formen sich gut in einen Stand verwandeln. Weil auch mit den Blättern so oben, ist so eine Art Dach. Ja, ist gut und auch so die Struktur mit diesen Samen aus. Der Arrested Development Bananenstand, war nur so lustig, weil er die Form einer Banane hat.
Willst du doch?
Ja, ja, hat er auch.
Aber ich finde das einfach grossartig.
Wenn du dir schon einen Laden besorgst,
der aussieht wie eine Frucht, dann committe dich verdammt nochmal.
Da musst du dann einfach sagen, nein,
ich bin jetzt Erdbeerverkäufer.
Ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, Moment mal, diese Fidgets in der Gegenrat gut, die verkaufe ich jetzt in meiner Erdbeere.
In meinem Karussell. Aber die hatten eine schwere Zeit tatsächlich, die Erdbeerenstandbesitzer, weil es wurden nicht so viele Erdbeeren geflückt. Nein, weil genau, oh jetzt kommt, jetzt weiß ich was, weil ich Radio höre, ich würde noch nicht fertig gemacht, weil ich Radio höre, macht man nicht mehr offensichtlich. Ich finde es toll, weil es diese Willkürlichkeit hat. Und zwar war es so, dass, ich vergesse leider auch immer, was ich im Radio ... Ach komm, du musst für Radio argumentieren, Stefan. Alle Radioprovinzenten da draußen sagen, ja, ja, ja, ja, bitte, sag es! Aber dann sind die Berichte oft nicht so geil. Was hast du gelehrt? Und dann denkt man manchmal, ich will lieber was anderes hören. Aber man ist so faul, das Augskabel, ausserdem rast man mit 280 über die Autobahn. Wenn ich jetzt nach dem Augskabel reiche, bin ich tot. Also bin ich in gewisser Weise als Radio gefesselt. Ja, aber irgendwann bringt dich das Radio doch dazu, dein Leben aufs Spiel zu sitzen, um nach dem Augskabel zu fingen. So, weil nämlich man erntet Erdbeere, ich war wieder bei Rhabarber, ist tut mir leid, man erntet Erdbeere stückeweise, also immer so in Schichten und dann kommen dann, wenn dann sind nämlich, kommen nämlich nochmal im Jahr Blüten. Und die werden dann zu den Erdbeeren. Aber als diese Blüten kamen, diese zweite Blütezeit, zweite Welle, kam um den ersten Mai herum ein grosser Frost nochmal. Und der hat alle Blüten zerstört, die die zweite Welle Erdbeeren geworden wären. Und zwar ist es um Eis, wie heißt denn dieser Tag noch mal? Der hat eine spezielle Erntezeit. Like Ice in the Sunshine? Speziellen Tag. Erdbeer. Eis. Und der Tag hatte eine spezielle Frostzeit und deswegen ist alles in die Brüche gegangen. Deswegen haben die sehr viele Erdbeeren und deswegen verstehe ich schon, dass sie zum Spargel greifen. Spargelkuchen, schönen Spargel mit Sahne. Macht doch Himbeeren wenigstens, weil das könnte ja auch einen Stand kurz umdekorieren. Ja, das stimmt. Die musst du ein bisschen einschmelzen, dann passt das schon. Aber ich finde zu dem Radiothema finde ich auch gut, es gibt ja auf der Autobahn... Eisheilige. Die Eisheiligen. An den Eisheiligen war noch mal kurz Frost. Hätte man auch drauf kommen können. Warum haben die in der Bibel nicht vor eigentlich? Sind so Mr. Freeze-Reise. Oh mein Gott, wie geil. Die wurden raus. Die Feuerheiligen. Bonusmaterial. Wo ist eigentlich das Bonusmaterial zur Bibel? Ja, die deleted scenes. Die ganzen deleted scenes. Die B-Roll. Die ganzen, vor allem, was ich auch, weil es gibt ja vier Evangelien haben wir ja, oder Evangelisten. Evangeliker. Die hatten doch bestimmt auch so die vier Elemente, oder? Lukas war so der Feuerevangelist, Matthäus so der Eisevangelist und einfach so. Lukas? Lukas hat einfach einen Baseballschläger, Lukas war der coolste und Lothar, Lothar und Matthäus. Ich glaube, ich finde vor allem, wenn man mal überdenkt, so vier Leute zusammen sind Vorbild für die Fantastischen vier, die Turtles. Das fängt bei den vier Evangelisten an. Das wäre mal das... Powerpuff Girls. Es sind drei. Gut, aber ausser du zählst Shredder noch dazu. Wen? Mojo Jojo. Nee, der ist nicht Shredder, Mojo Jojo. Das ist ja ein Bösewicht. Egal. Da sehen wir mal, wie weit wir gekommen sind von den vier Evangelisten. Die, glaube ich, sind auch ein Dreamteam eigentlich. Könnte man das nicht so in die Neuzeit verfrachten, so die jungen vier Evangelisten, die Verbrechen lösen oder so? Ist auf eine Art American Gods wahrscheinlich, nur nicht mit ganz vielen, sondern da müsste man die Bibel mal durchziehen. Ich bin ja großer Fan von Supernatural, mittlerweile glaube ich der einzige Fan von Supernatural, und da gibt's ja wirklich dann ab und zu, taucht dann so der Erzengel Gabriel auf in der Neuzeit, immer mal wieder so alte Bekannte, man denkt, wow, den kenn ich doch. Und das wäre natürlich cool, wenn man das mit den Eisheiligen zum Beispiel hinkriegen könnte. Oh, die wären so geil. Und aber auch. Die vier Evangelisten gegen die Eisheiligen, das wäre eine Staffel. Lukas, Matthäus, Markus und Johannes, ne? Ja, nicht schlecht. Ist das Johannes der Täufer? Nein, ganz andere Johannes. Ganz andere, das eine ist Jojo, das andere ist Johnny. Aber es gibt auch zum Thema Radio, es gibt ja auf der Autobahn immer so diese Warnplakate, ne? Da siehst du dann so einen Sarg und dann, weil sie auf die SMS antworten wollte. Weil sie WDR 2 gehört hat. Genau, also so einen Sarg und dann, weil ihr der Radiosender nicht gefallen hat, FM4. FM4, passt auf euch auf, gute Fahrt. Hört uns und ihr sterbt, ihr sterbt, wenn ihr versucht, die Radiosender zu wissen. Ich habe mal so einen Twitter-Tweet, so einen Twitter-Tweet rausgehauen, getweetet, weil ich es lustig fand, weil ich diese Plakate wahnsinnig ablenkend finde. Ich frage mich eigentlich, ob mal jemand gestorben ist, weil er auf dieses Pass auf, ich bin gestorben Schild geguckt hat. Ich bin gestorben, weil ich auf ein Wahnplakat geguckt habe. Ich wurde abgelenkt von einem Wahnplakat. Weil er sich von Osnabrück, die Stadt der Seen, hat ablenken gelassen Ja, Kölner Dom, UNESCO-Weltkulturerbe. So ein ganzer Kampf zwischen verschiedenen Warenplakaten an der Autobahnseite. Hat man sich für blau entschieden als Autobahnfarbe, weil das gut zu sehen ist, angenehm ist? Angenehme Farbe. Guter Kontrast auch? Ja, es ist halt so himmelblau. Ich glaube, da fliegen dann die Vögel nicht dagegen, oder? Kann schon sein.
Fliegen die nicht gerade in den Himmel?
Ja, die weisse Strift auf blauem Hintergrund ist eigentlich eine Vogelgefahr.
Vogelgefahr. Das ist eine richtige Vogelgefahr.
Klassische FF.
Es ist schon verrückt, dass so viele Flugzeuge Vogelprobleme haben, aber Autos gar nicht.
So ein Storch oder so null.
Ne, Mückenproblem.
Ja?
Man fliegt häufig in Mücken. Oder so ein Bienenproblem. Wenn eine Biene im Auto ist, ist das dann auch ein großes Problem. Oh, das sieht man aber auch selten auf diesen Autobahn-Post an. Nicht eine grinsende Biene, weil sie Leute mitgenommen haben, die sie nicht kennen. So ein totes Kleinkind auf der Rückbank und da ruft einfach nur eine Biene im Auto. Das ist ein Wahnbild. Eine Biene, die so den Daumen rausstreckt und hinter dem Rücken so ein Messer hat und dann einfach so, nehmt keine Bienen mit.
Das ist oft so, eine SMS hat mich umgebracht und so. Ich finde es auch geil, wenn die Geschichten absurder werden. So ein Waschbär im Auto, fragt nicht oder sowas. Wir hatten Waschbär im Auto, Leute. Ach, ich kam von meinen Großeltern, die haben da diesen Hof. Na, komm. Pinguine auf der A3, weirde Geschichte, seid vorsichtig. Lange Geschichte, und ein anderes Schild erzählen wir ein anderes Mal. Lange Geschichte. Das wollte ich ja immer noch einführen auf deutschen Autobahnen.
Also ein Daumenkino, ne?
Ein Daumenkino, das einen dazu bringt, dass man eine gewisse Geschwindigkeit fährt.
Weil es macht gar keinen Sinn, glaube ich.
Ach so, wenn du schnell fährst, dann kriegst du die Story nicht mit.
Und du musst nochmal zurückfahren und umdrehen.
Du musst umdrehen, U-Turn machen, dann hast du Falschfahrer.
Anderes Problem.
Nein, aber es gibt ja diese geilen Bodenhubbel in diesen Seitenmarkierungen. Und die merkst du nur, wenn du zu schnell fährst. Oder zu langsam wahrscheinlich nicht. Und wenn du die richtige Geschwindigkeit fährst, dann stört es nicht. Wenn du zu langsam fährst, dann geben die dir so einen Boost wie bei F-Zero. Genau. Dass du dann noch ein bisschen angetrieben wirst. Wie bei Super Mario, diese Regenbogendinger. Genau. Aber das denke ich mir auch, wie wie geil das wäre, wenn du links Plakate hättest und da ist irgendwie so eine Folge Spongebob oder sowas, können dann die Kinder gucken, beim Rausgucken, wenn der Papa die richtige Geschwindigkeit fährt. Schneller, schneller, schneller, schneller, es macht gar keinen Sinn. Schneller, Patrick ist so langsam. Ja, aber der ist so langsam. Schwierig. Immer von Ausfahrt zu Ausfahrt und dann zwingen die Kinder den auch teilweise zu gewissen Autobahnabschnitten zu fahren. Sieh aber noch ein bisschen was vom Land, um gewisse Folgen zu sehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das eine gute Idee ist, dass der Konsument die Geschwindigkeit selber in der Hand haben sollte. Ich fange mich, ich muss mich manchmal einfangen. Ich bin manchmal auf YouTube im Geschwindigkeitsrausch. Bin ich sehr ehrlich, ich schaue mir eine Vortragsreihe an, wieder irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Hofrenkespiele im Spaniern des 17. Jahrhunderts, das ist ein Nachmittag für mich, und dann schaue ich zehnstündige Vortragsreihe. Ist es dann immer genau das, was du nachgesucht hast, oder findet dich das Thema? Nee, mich findet das. Nee, nee, eine gute Doku findet dich. Und dann fängst du mit dem ersten Teil an und fängst auf Geschwindigkeit 1,0 an, Und dann sagst du, komm, 1,2 gehst du hoch und irgendwann 1,5. Und dann denkst du, man gewöhnt sich ja dran, man gewöhnt sich ja nach zehn Minuten an die neue Geschwindigkeit und dann komm, 1,8 gehst du hoch, Geschwindigkeit. Und irgendwann bin ich auf zweieinhalbfacher Geschwindigkeit und baller dadurch. Ist das beim Sprechen auch so, denke ich mir. Reden wir mittlerweile schneller miteinander, weil wir uns schon an eine gewisse Geschwindigkeit gewöhnt haben? Oder waren die Menschen damals, haben die nicht immer auch gewählter geschrieben? Da ist mehr Arbeit und Zeit reingeflossen in so einen Brief. Ja, aber auch weil Tinte teuer war. Du musstest jedes Mal so einen Oktopus fangen, den irgendwie ausquetschen. Und dann hattest du irgendwie so eine Pfütze Tinte und hast gesagt, so, jetzt schreibe ich an den König. Das war doch nie. Pass mal auf. Nein. Doch. Wo kam denn so eine normale Tinte her? Na ja, Tintenfisch? Nee. Ja, was meinst du, wenn der Tintenfisch heisst? Weil der so aussieht wie Tinte. Nein, weil der Tinte spritzt, wenn der wütend ist. Das heißt ja auch Kugelfisch, nicht weil es als Kugel benutzt wird. Weiss man nicht? Du musst erst mal zu einem Tintenfisch gehen, den ärgern, den so, ne, ne ne, acht arm, acht arm. Wo kommt ein Schwert daher? Und dann spritzt er dich an. Ja, Säbelzähne, wo kommen Säbel her? Wo kommen Säbelzähne her? Das habe ich mich echt schon oft gefragt. Und es war auf jeden Fall aufwendiger. Ich glaube, heute schreibst du da so deine Bits und Bites. Da rotst du da hin, egal. Bitt, ne, gibt's kein Tier.
Vielleicht sollte man Emojis reduzieren, dass man nur noch so ein Emoji pro Tag hat, dass man ihn wirklich wählen muss.
So ein Emoji kriegt, man wirklich sagt, wow, danke für dieses Pferd.
Ich war heute neulich sehr arrogant.
Möchtest du dich entschuldigen?
Ich muss mich entschuldigen bei einem lieben Kollegen, mit dem ich abends den Arm verbracht habe, und der hat eine chinesische Partnerin. Und ich war dann, und der lernt auch gerade die chinesischen Schriftzeichen. Und ich war dann so, mal wieder, habe ich mich erwischt, wie Arroganz Stefan durchkommt langsam. Und ich habe dann so gesagt, ja, aber jetzt mal unter uns, die chinesen schriftzeichen machen ja nicht so richtig sind die sind alle wahnsinnig sind alle so wahnsinnig komplex alle wahnsinnig komplex sonne so ich kann auch lieber ich kann auch schneller eine sonne malen als das symbol für sonne aufzuzeichnen und das das Gespräch ist sehr nach hinten losgegangen, weil es das komplette Gegenteil ist, der Fall. Weil dann hat er gesagt, okay, dann mal ich dir mal kurz das Symbol für Sonne auf. Und es war einfach nur wie so ein Kreis mit einem Strich drin. Und man sagt, ja gut, das war deutlich schneller. Es war sogar deutlich schneller, als wenn ich jetzt Sonne malen, also schreiben müsste. Da habe ich gesagt, ist unsere Schriftart plötzlich die irrationale Schriftart. Wir könnten einfach eine Sonne malen, das wäre schneller. Warum schreiben wir Sonne aus? Macht keinen Sinn. Sonnenuntergang. Kannst einfach eine halbe Sonne malen. Ja. Und machst einen Pfeil runter. Wie schneller als Sonnenuntergang zu schreiben. Guck mal, letzte Woche haben wir noch die Hieroglyphen gebashed und hier ausgelacht und uns lustig gemacht über die dummen Ägypten. Jetzt müssen wir uns zurückziehen. Jetzt müssen wir uns das zurücknehmen. Genau. Also große Revisionnahme. Ja. Und dann hat er mir gezeigt, weil ich habe gesagt, warum haben die nicht einfach Dinge gemalt? Und dann kam raus, dass wahrscheinlich diese Zeichen auch aus einem, eine krasse Abstraktion von kleinen Kalligrafien, von kleinen Zeichnungen. Zum Beispiel, wenn du dir das anguckst, das Wort Mensch oder Mann ist einfach nur im Prinzip ein vereinfachtes Strichmännchen. Und dann hat er gezeigt, dass Mann, das Schriftzeichen für Mann, ist eine Mischung aus Feld und Kraft. Also das ist oft auch einfach so zusammengesetzt. Kraftfeld. Kraftfeld. Jemand, der Kraft auf dem Feld angewandt hat. Ach so, okay. Ja, das sind Männer. Feldkraftarbeiter. Und das war sehr interessant, da habe ich mich kurz mitgenommen in dieser Welt. Und tatsächlich konnte er wahnsinnig schnell sehr komplexe Wörter aufzeichnen, die im Deutschen deutlich schneller, deutlich länger bräuchten. Fand ich super interessant, weil ich habe es immer ein bisschen abgetan als Quatschschrift. So laufen deine Abende ab. Ja. Du triffst dich mit jemandem, beleidigst die Freundin und lässt dich dann belehren über zweieinhalb Stunden, warum du ein Idiot bist. Kleinlaut belehren und dann gehen wir wieder auseinander und ich wundere mich, warum ich nie wieder eingeladen werde. Das war ein schöner Abend, das sollten wir wieder machen. Ja, wir melden uns. Wir denken mal drüber nach. Ja, nein. Oder einfach nicht. Nee, das war, natürlich war ich nicht so ein wahnsinniges Arschloch, aber ich hatte bislang wirklich gedacht, dass es so eine, ein bisschen so an einer Tradition festkrallende Tradition ist. Du willst auch da eine Revision starten? Gerne Revision. Du, probier es mal, probier es einfach mal. Die Revision? Ja. Jetzt? Aber haben die denn eigentlich auch so Schriftarten?
Kursiv.
Haben wir auch gefragt.
Also kann man denn als Illustrator, können sie in Deutschland, können sie sich ja verwirklichen mit dem, was haben wir?
Also gibt es Comic Sans für chinesische Schriftzeichen?
Also kann man das umsetzen oder gibt es dann, weiss man nicht.
Kann man kursiv?
Ich weiß es nicht genau. Aber du könntest auch nicht kursiv schreiben. Was ist mit einem Kreuzworträtsel? Und dann meinte er, weil er hat jetzt ein Kind bekommen, und da geht es weniger darum, wie die heißen, als wie das Schriftzeichen für den Namen aussieht. Die hat ein eigenes Zeichen. Nee, aber du kannst halt den Namen Jong mein meinetwegen, auf eine Milliarde verschiedene Zeichen darstellen. Und viele heißen so, es geht eher darum geht es nicht, wie du heisst, es geht darum, wie es aussieht, geschrieben. Und jetzt hat der Vater sich, der Schwiegervater von ihm, sich so ein ganz weirdes Zeichen rausgesucht, was wahnsinnig schön ist, aber was kaum existiert. Und es gab Probleme am Flughafen, weil, und da haben sich wieder tausend andere Fragen aufgegeben, weil es das Zeichen nicht gab.
Die konnten es nicht darstellen, die konnten es nicht schreiben, die konnten das Ticket nicht formulieren für das Kind.
Weil die im Computer das nicht hatten.
Weil die das Zeichen nicht hatten, ja. Da mussten die das...
Also es gibt irgendwie so zehntausend Zeichen.
Meine Güte.
Und so krasse Chinesen sprechen, dreitausend Zeichen können die ausser Lameng raushauen. Was ist das Zeichen für Lameng? Das ist nachgefragt. So eine rote Nase. Ja, gut, okay, dann sind wir jetzt schon in der Entschuldigungsrubrik. Dann können wir ja gleich nochmal zurückgreifen auf letzte Woche, wo wir nämlich aufgeworfen haben, ich möchte es kurz beenden, weil ich habe ein bisschen recherchiert. Wir können kurz, sollen wir kurz in Podcast UFO investigativ einsteigen? Das Podcast UFO investigativ! Investigativ, tief, tief, tief, tief, tief, und zwar Fluch der Karibik, haben wir überlegt. Und ich habe ja damit gerechnet, wir haben aufgeworfen, wie ist genau die Hierarchie zwischen Commodore und Norrington. Und ich dachte mir, ah, da kann man sich mal auf die Podcast UFO Community verlassen, da gibt verlassen, da gibt es bestimmt einen Militähistoriker oder irgendwie jemanden, der in der Schifffahrt aktiv ist, der mir das genau erklärt. Oder zumindest ein Fan, der recherchiert. Nichts! Gar nichts! Tausend unlustige Cornflakes und Wissenschaftler-Gags, die nicht funktioniert haben, keiner ist lustiger als Fruit Notes, keiner wird hier erwähnt. Viele Vorwürfe auf, warum wir nicht auf Kellogg's Drostys gekommen sind. Ach Gott, aber das glaube ich, also, das muss ich, wir haben angefangen mit dem Gag Kellogg's Drostys, wegen Drosten. Und dann kamen wir darauf, oh, wir kreuzen Cornflakes mit Wissenschaftlern, haben das nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt und haben gesagt, warum ist es eigentlich nicht Kellogg's Drostys eingefahren. Ich glaube, obwohl wir es damit angefangen haben, ich glaube, das ist eine Form von Mandela-Effekt. Ich glaube, die haben das im Hinterkopf, aber nicht ganz abgespeichert richtig. Menschen finden sich zu toll. Wie oft denke ich mir, ach wie genial, das jetzt war mein Gedanke, den muss ich erst mal kundtun und dann auf dem Weg des Kundtuns fällt mir auf, aha gut, wurde entweder schon gemacht, war nicht mein Gedanke, es ist völliger Unsinn, weil ich habe gerade geträumt und in der Realität macht das keinen Sinn.
Deswegen auch immer erstmal googeln, bevor man postet. Ich google immer und denke mir, what, das ist ein J-Lo-Song, das ist ein Lyrick aus einem J-Lo-Song, fuck. Du hast den Song selber komponiert, in deinem Kopf. Ja, darauf bin ich gekommen. Put a ring on it. Scheisse, das ist nicht von mir.
So, das heisst, ich musste mal wieder selber hinabsteigen in die Untiefen der historischen Korrektheit, weil mir niemand geholfen hat. Unsere Frage war, wie interagieren die Ränge Commodore, Norrington, das Fluch der Karibik und Governor Swann? So, also, wir fangen mal an. Wann spielt Fluch der Karibik? Äh, ja so, East Indian. Schätz mal, schätz mal. East Indian Zeit. Gib mir mal eine Zahl. Gib mir mal eine Zahl. Wir machen hier interaktiven Unterricht, okay? Das ist jetzt hier keine ... 1746. Gar nicht schlecht, zwischen 1720 und 1750. Sehr gut, fantastisch. Wie du dich freust, heißt, dass es geraten war. Jaaten war. So, der Film beginnt mit Norrington als Lieutenant. Ich bin ganz aufgeregt. Lieutenant und wird dann zu einem Commodore befördert. Commodore! So wie ich es verstanden habe, ist ein Lieutenant in der Seefahrt damals im 18. Jahrhundert ein Kapitänleutnant und ist sowas wie jemand, der potenziell Kapitän eines Schiffs sein kann. Ja, der kann, wenn er auf dem Schiff aktiv ist, ist er auf dem Kapitän. Jetzt kommt Kapitän plötzlich daher. Er wird nämlich auch manchmal Kapitän genannt, Captain Norrington. Jetzt ist aber, so wie ich es verstanden habe, Kapitän der Ausdruck für den Chef eines Schiffs. Dieser Chef kann aber verschiedene Ränge annehmen, wenn jetzt natürlich ein hochrangiger Offizier kann auch Captain sein. Das heißt, Captain ist kein eigener Begriff, so habe ich es, glaube ich, verstanden. Und deswegen ist sein Rang Lieutenant, kann aber auch Captain sein. So, als Commodore kann er auch Captain sein, wenn er auf einem Schiff ist, aber ein Commodore ist jetzt jemand, der mehreren Schiffen vorsteht, einem Geschwader Schiffen vorsteht. Aber dann verstehe ich den, okay, dann verstehe ich den zwischen Captain und Lieutenant aber nicht. Also der Captain ist einem Schiff zugeordnet, Lieutenant kann auch von einem anderen Schiff der Captain sein. Sagen wir mal so, der Captain ist der Lehrer der Klasse, aber auch der Rektor kann auch der Lehrer der Klasse sein. Der Lehrer ist einfach nur der Vorsteher dieser Klasse. So, und aber der Rektor kann zusätzlich auch noch der ganzen Schule vorstehen, kann aber auch Geschichtsunterricht. Kann aber auch einen Geschichtsunterricht machen. Und genau der Commodore ist so wie der Rektor, der viele Klassen unter sich hat, aber natürlich auch mal an einem schönen Donnerstagnachmittag in eine Klasse gehen kann und sagen, ich übernehme jetzt hier und kann dann auch ein Schiff befehligen. So, das ist der Kommode, also das war die Überlegung von einem normalen Kapitän.
Das ist jetzt alles an Wasser, auf Wasser.
Das ist zu Wasser.
Das war uns ein bisschen verwirrt, weil die Amtsvereiligung hat ja an Land stattgefunden,
in dieser Feste.
Ja, so, jetzt kommen wir zu Governor Swann, Vorname Weatherby.
Weatherby Swann.
Weatherby Swann, Governor Weatherby Swann. Warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte Ich habe so Bock auf den Film. Das ist die Hauptstadt der Kolonie Jamaika. Jamaika? Ich weiss nicht, englischer Ausbruch mit Jamaika, englische Kolonie, Jamaika, davon die Hauptstadt Port Royal, von dieser Hauptstadt ist Swan der Governor, der Stadthalter. Ist Port Royal wirklich eine Stadt, kann man da heute hin? Ja, also ich glaube, heute gibt es ja diese Kolonie nicht mehr, das heißt, wahrscheinlich heißt es jetzt anders. Ich wusste ja, es ist ja auch Amerika-Spiel. Naja, es ist ja Fluch der Karibik. Ja, aber mich gefragt, hätte ich wahrscheinlich gesagt, also England. Naja, technisch gesehen ist es Teil von England als Kolonie. So, das heißt, Governor ist der Stadthalter, der Hauptstadt dieser ganzen Kolonie, dieses Landes sozusagen.
Also du bist ein sehr...
Ja. So, jetzt haben wir also sozusagen zwei Arten von Hierarchien. Governor ist, also so würde ich es formulieren, der Governor ist eher ein Politiker, wohingegen der Commodore eher ein Offizier im Militär ist. Richtig. Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage des Zuständigkeitsbereichs, weil ja sind es natürlich einige Schiffe in Port Royal angelegt, wo natürlich die Royal Navy, also das Militär des Sachen hat. Wir machen gerade full blown Star Wars 1 mit Plutiker Riewick. Genau. Also das ist wirklich, wenn wir jetzt mit der Prequel Trilogie von Plutiker Riewick beauftragt worden wären, würden wir vollblown, Handelsföderation, Verträge, wer ist der Vorsteher, wo liegt das genau? Aufwendiger Wahlkampf, Infiltration, Wirtschaftsprobleme, was ist mit den Schildkröten im Riff? So, und jetzt haben wir das Ding, weil ich glaube, normalerweise ist innerhalb der Stadt der Governor der Chef, weil der ist sozusagen der Vorsteher der ganzen Stadt, weil Port Royal ist auch eine militärische Stadt, das heißt, es gibt Interaktionen zwischen Militär und Stadt, aber, und da gibt es ja die Szenen in dem Film, die habe ich mir nochmal angeguckt, weil normalerweise ist der Governor Swan der Chef gegenüber Norrington, der ist ja auch bei der Beförderung leitend, nur in dem Moment, in dem die Black Pearl angreift und es zu Kampfhandlungen kommt, so interpretiere es ich, kann der Commodore als Offizier dem Governor Befehle geben im Sinne von wir kämpfen jetzt, jetzt habe ich das Sagen, jetzt tust du was ich sage. Aber auch nur als Commodore, als Präsident hätte er es nicht gekonnt, weil er sagt, das ist ein Befehl. Genau, das kann schon sein. Gehen Sie, fliehen Sie. Es kann gut sein, dass er als Commodore der höchstrangige Offizier der Royal Navy in diesem Bereich ist und somit auch dem Governor was befehlen kann, im Kriegszustand. Ich erinnere mich noch sehr gut an Governor Swann, wie geschockt er auf die Schüssel der Black Pearl reagiert und da ganz angst erfüllt rumschaut und seine Perücke anfängt zu wackeln und dann Kommodore Neu ein Fall mit dem Stehen und sagt, gehen Sie, das ist ein Befehl. Und da ging erst mal eine Welle durchs Publikum. Ja, mein Kinosaal stand auf den Füssen. Moment mal, der ist doch der Governor! Die Hälfte wollte immer noch das Eis, der ist schon weggefahren, der mal mit dem Eis. Die andere Hälfte summt immer noch die Melodie vom Anfang. Ich frage, warum ist das nicht so ein grosser Hit? Das ist ein grosser Hit. Das wird immer noch in Clubs gespielt heutzutage. Das ist immer noch He's a Pirate. Ich meine die des Franchise. Weil die anderen Filme so schlecht waren. Furchtbar waren. Ja, aber Star Wars ja auch, aber das haben die haben die anderen noch besser gemacht irgendwie. Naja, aber das ist auf jeden Fall die Situation zwischen Governor Swann und Commodore Norrington. So, muss sich alles selber rausfinden. Vielen Dank für nichts, liebe Podcast-Ufo-Community. Vielen Dank für diesen Skip von drei Minuten, die Leute können jetzt wieder zurückkommen, wenn sie Stefans Alltagsgeschichte haben. Aber auch gut, dass wir offensichtlich auf die Community insofern scheissen, als das ein Thema aufgekommen ist, was die gar nicht interessiert und wir jetzt innerhalb von acht Minuten für uns auseinander gedröselt haben, wo der Unterschied zwischen Commodore und Governor ist. Die Zuhörer müssen sich mit der Idee versöhnen, dass dieser Podcast langsam aber sicher zu einem Fluch der Karibik-Fan-Podcast wird. Ob ihr das wollt oder nicht, ist uns egal. So, von dir will ich nächste Woche nämlich hören, was es mit dem Fluch von Cortez auf sich hat. Gibt es da historische Hintergründe? Wie viele Metallmünzen muss man klauen? Wann wurde der gefunden? Was ist da los? Und so bilden wir uns jetzt jede Woche fort. Hast du übrigens meine subtile
Futur-Karibik-Referenz verstanden in unserem Chatverlauf?
Da hast du dann mal wieder nach dem Instagram-Passwort gefragt.
Und ich habe gefragt, jetzt willst du zu viel.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Habe ich geschrieben, hast du nicht ...
Habe ich nicht verstanden.
Nein.
Ist das ein Zitat aus FDK?
Ja, unser Lieblingsfilm sagt nämlich die Zimmerdame von Elizabeth Swann, auch für deutsche Zungen, fantastisch auszusprechen, Elizabeth Swann, da sagt er, dieser William Turner, das ist auch ein, jetzt geht mir die Buchablau. Eine gute Partie ist auch eine gute Partie, genau, auch eine gute Partie. Jetzt willst du zu viel. Oh, jetzt wagst du zu viel. Jetzt wagst du zu viel, jetzt gehst du zu weit. Jetzt gehst du zu weit, das ist nicht mit deinem Stand angemessen, in Summe zu reden. Also, sie entschuldigt sich und geht, dann wollte ich auch immer diese Wärme. Ich wollte es gerade sagen, das sind glühende Kohlen, also Elisabeth Storm. Oh mein Gott, aber da ist nicht so, dass da irgendwie eine Decke drum kommt oder sowas. Nein. Die schläft mit glühenden Kohlen.
So, wir müssen jetzt leider das Fluchtecker-Ribrik-Segment noch ein bisschen erweitern, weil Elizabeth Swan ist anscheinend zu kalt in ihrem Bett, weswegen sie so eine Art, naja, wie so eine Maroni-Pfanne hat, wo ihre Zofe, es ist im Grunde ein Druckkocher, in der Zofe glühende Kohlen reintut und es ins Bett tut. Punkt eins, dieser Film spielt in der Karibik. Wie kann es einem dazu kalt sein? werden. Also sorry, aber das ist ja in der, wirklich in der Karibik. Wir wissen nicht, ob Winter.
Aber ich nicht verstanden habe, war noch nie in Singapur gewesen, was? Ja, aber das ist einer dieser Sätze.
Ja, aber das ist ja die Idee. Das ist ja die Idee. Aber in Teil drei versteht man es dann. Ja, das stimmt. Gut, also, so viel zum Thema. Sorry, wir sind mal wieder ein bisschen abgedriftet. Ich möchte kurz sagen, denn statt uns die Unterschiede zwischen Commodore und Governor aufzudröseln, habt ihr euch ein bisschen anders fokussiert in der letzten Woche, nämlich auf mein, ich nenne es mal H&M-Paketproblem, das Nachbarschaftsproblem. Vielen Dank für die vielen Vorschläge. Ich würde es sexy Problem nennen. Ich glaube, es ist das sexieste Thema, das wir jemals hatten, oder? Das ist auch unscheiss, ich glaube, viele andere Podcasts machen mehr mit Sexappeal. Ja, wir brauchen mehr Sexappeal. Ja, guck dir auch dich an. Wir brauchen mehr so schlüpfrige Stories. Von mir kannst du dir nichts erwarten. Nee, ich meine auch so in den Beschreibungen, Titelbeschreibungen und so. Ah ja, okay. Und vielleicht, dass wir, keine Ahnung, Beschreibungstexte, Titel der Folgen. Okay, wir werden schmutziger. Ja, ein bisschen, weil ich glaube, das wollen Leute hören. Okay, gut, dann lass mal die Hüllen fallen jetzt. Also meine sexy hot hot xxx Story, und zwar diese Story, die ja war. Ich mache ein Paket auf von einer Nachbarin, ohne das zu wissen, und in dem Paket sind, ja, ganz viele unsittliche Dinge. Unterwäsche, ja. Unterwäsche, im Kern einfach Unterwäsche. So, jetzt habe ich es aber auch gemacht und musste es halt eher irgendwie geben. Viele Vorschläge gab es, wie man damit umverfahren kann. Genau. Zum Beispiel, was ich den besten Vorschlag fand, den ich gerne prämieren möchte hiermit. Ich bestelle, ich habe den Namen leider vergessen, ich bestelle mir die gleichen Sachen, ich sehe die Sachen auf dem Lieferschein, nochmal auf ihren Namen direkt dahin. Halte ich für eine, in der Theorie erstmal auf dem Papier, für eine fantastische Idee, für die perfekte Idee. Nachteil, wenn sie was nicht behält aus der Sendung, die sie erhält, ist es problematisch. Aber kannst du wie gesagt nicht einfach irgendwie... Dann kriege ich das Geld nämlich zurück. Nee, aber du bestellst ihre Bestellung noch mal zu dir. Ganz kurz, bevor du jetzt weiter reingehst. Das Problem ist mittlerweile gelöst worden von mir. Ich möchte noch nicht verraten wie. Aber okay, jetzt fahr fort. Aber könntest du nicht ihre Bestellung nochmal an dich bestellen, dann den Bestellschein der alten Lieferung abknibbeln, auf die neue Lieferung kleben und ihr so das Paket geben? Dann dürfte sie nur nicht das abknibbeln, um die schändliche Spur deines Verbrechens zu finden, aber dann hättest du ja eigentlich, außer dass die Lieferung zu spät kommt, alles gelöst. Aber ich bin sehr gespannt, wie du es gelöst hast. Die meisten Leute haben nämlich auch gesagt, Stefan, lass ruhig angehen, solche Dinge kommen irgendwann raus, sage die Wahrheit. Und tatsächlich, mir fällt übrigens gerade auf, dass die Community zum ersten Mal, weil wir unser Aufnahmedatum geändert haben, gar nicht so viel Zeit hat zu reagieren auf die Folgen. Anderes Thema, feld mir gerade auf. Deswegen können wir nämlich gerade nicht alle Informationen zurate ziehen, weil wahrscheinlich die meisten kommen erst noch. Ja, aber die besten Nachrichten kommen eh immer so vor. Okay, ihr müsst euch in Zukunft sputen, am besten so innerhalb von zwei Minuten nach Hören der Folge. Leute, ballert direkt eure Sachen drauf. So, ich habe folgendermaßen es gemacht, ich mache den neuen Stefan, den 2020er Stefan, und der Stefan ist offen und ehrlich und läuft mit dem BH auf dem Kopf in die Nachbarwohnung und sagt Sorry, sorry. Nein, ich habe das Paket genommen, ich habe es so gut alles, es geht wieder, ich habe das auch ein bisschen aufgerissen, so gut es geht reingemacht wieder, also die Sachen gefaltet und so reingelegt, dass es irgendwie so aussah wie versehentlich geöffnet. hab dann mein Paket, das andere, was ich bekommen habe, mitgenommen, um zu beweisen, dass es sehr ähnlich war.
Gehe hin und gehe raus, merke, ah fuck, ich weiß gar nicht, wer das eigentlich jetzt genau ist, diese Nachbarin. Frage eine andere Nachbarin, wer ist denn das? Stellt sich raus, in dem Haus arbeiten auch manche Menschen, da ist eine Werbeagentur zum Beispiel drin, ich gehe also zu dieser Werbeagentur, ist alles modernes Open Living, heißt da war einfach natürlich die Tür sperrgeweite auf. Tischtennis, Aquarium, Kicker und so weiter. Ich bin rein und fünf Männer starren auf mich, weil ich plötzlich an der Tür stehe, an ihrem Laptop. Ja, dann habe ich gesagt, arbeitet eine so und so bei euch. Ich habe nämlich ein Paket angenommen. Und dann dachte ich, die holen die jetzt, damit ich ihr das Paket geben kann und die Story erklären kann. Stattdessen nimmt der, der am weitesten wechselt von mir das Gespräch auf, kommt zu mir und sagt, nee, kannst du mir ruhig geben. Ja. Und nur mit zwei Paketen in der Hand, dem Vergleichsobjekt, dem Beweisobjekt. Dann habe ich gesagt, okay, folgendes, könnt ihr ihr bitte sagen, und jetzt haben, in diesem Zeitpunkt hatten alle die Hörkopfhörer aufgenommen, alle Noisecanceling-Devices rausgenommen, um mich anzugucken. Hörgerät reingesteckt. Hörgerät reingesteckt, Enhancer reingesteckt, Google Glasses aufgesetzt, wer ist das da? Alle Aufmerksamkeit war auf mich gerichtet, weil ich gesagt habe, könnt ihr bitte sagen, dass ich es aus Versehen aufgemacht habe, weil ich dieses ähnliche Paket auch bekommen habe. Es tut mir total leid, könnt ihr es bitte sagen. Und der ganze Raum, nur Männer, okay, ja sagen wir, grosses Gelächter in dem Raum, und jetzt dachte ich mir, okay, was kann schlimm sein, wenn ich mit offenen Karten spiele, ja, das ist in etwa das Worst-Case-Szenario, weil wenn sie jetzt dieses Paket, erstmal hört sie, alle Männer, die saßen einfach unten in der Etage, ich bin oben gewesen, alle Männer hat sie lachen gehört, jetzt kriegt sie das Paket mit dem Spruch, ja das hat aber aufgemacht, was ist denn da drin, obwohl ich jetzt keinen Scheiss bestellt und alle Männer in dem Büro haben gelacht und der dusselige Nachbar, Teenager Nachbar hat das dann gemacht. Äh, ja, also seitdem habe ich sie aber nicht mehr gesehen, ich weiss auch gar nicht genau, wer das ist. Ähm, ja, ein bisschen...
Ja, du, das ist der Preis für Ehrlichkeit.
Wie gesagt, ich glaube, wir haben alle
eine Lektion gelernt, und zwar
nicht ehrlich sein. Nicht ehrlich sein?
Also wenn ihr eins mitnehmen könnt, von dieser Folge.
Probleme vertuschen, vermeiden, untern Teppich
damit. Aber es ist ja nicht ganz so
schlimm, wenn sie da nicht wohnt, oder? Ich glaube, es wäre
wahrscheinlich unangenehmer gewesen, wenn sie
da gewohnt hätte, als wenn sie da nur
arbeitet. Ist natürlich auch unangenehm, aber auf kurz oder lang die Kündigung erzwingen. Das ist halt jetzt der nächste Schritt. Damit diese unangenehme Person raus ist jetzt. Ja, also wenn ihr eins mitnimmt von dieser Folge, dann zumindest vielleicht, dass man nicht ehrlich sein sollte. Ja. Sondern ab und zu auch einfach mal lügt. Macht schön, hört euch Kopfhör rein, macht den Ocean's Eleven Soundtrack an und macht einen coolen Plan, überlegt euch irgendeine coole Strategie, macht Spaß. Sucht euch einen kleinen Asiaten, Matt Damon, genau, noch ein paar Leute und dann macht ihr einen Plan. Eine gute Show. Ich liebe das, den Ocean's Eleven Soundtrack rein sind, haben wir auch schon mal gesagt, den Trick, Ocean's Eleven Soundtrack ins Ohr und die Welt laufen, wo man denkt sofort, man wüsste, was man tut. Ja, das ist ganz fantastisch. Also würde man vielleicht selber nicht den Plan wissen, aber es gibt einen Plan. Ja. Ich habe jetzt auch, also ich weiß nicht, ich bin jetzt übergegangen zu laut Musik hören. Ich habe sonst immer nur über Kopfhörer Musik gehört, aber ich mache jetzt manchmal laut Musik und dann bin ich auch durchaus manchmal ein bisschen tänzerisch aufgelegt, muss ich ehrlich. Also weil die Rhythmen machen was mit meinem Körper und dann gibt es auch mal ein kleines, ja dann ist die Hüfte auch mal, sag ich mal, in der Luft und wackelt, hin und her und vom rechts und links und kreist sozusagen und ja, macht Spaß und ich habe das jetzt wirklich für mich entdeckt so normalerweise. Man muss auch sagen, du hast ja Instagram auch für dich entdeckt. Ey, ich bin angekommen. 2020 ist mein Jahr, ich bin angekommen und ich habe Bock drauf. Also folgt uns auf jeden Fall auf Instagram, das Podcast UFO. Heisser Content erwartet euch, Sticker. Wenn ihr darüber nachgedacht habt, uns zu entfolgen, dann tut es jetzt. Umfragen, hey, was wollt ihr mehr, weniger Content, klick links, klick rechts. Nein, Leute, einfach entfolgen, jetzt entfolgen. Weil jetzt hat Flo und die Kontrolle über den Instagram-Account übernommen. Und jetzt wird es, also muss man sagen, nicht mehr so stilsicher. Ja, aber das ist mein Ziel. Ich will am Stilbaum rütteln.
Ich will wackeln.
Ich will, dass da was unterfällt. Ja, was soll da runterfallen?
Ich raff's auch nicht. Follower.
Ich check's auch von hinten bis vorne nicht.
Ich hab schon so viele Sachen gepostet
und dann schamvoll direkt wieder gelöscht.
Da sind auch sehr private Fotos, weil ich es einfach nicht
gecheckt habe am Anfang. Aber mittlerweile geht's
einigermaßen. Ich glaube, das krieg ich schon hin mit den Story.
Auf unserem Kanal hast du private Fotos veröffentlicht? Ist nicht so wichtig, aber auf jeden Fall viele unangenehme Sachen. Aber naja, so geht es weiter. So ist langsam bereit. Ich finde, manchmal muss man auch Sachen immer dieses, na, du bist dem Trend hinterher, ja mein Gott, so, manchmal muss man auch einfach spät einsteigen zu Sachen, dann passt, ist auch okay. Keine Scham vor spätem Einstieg, so, es gibt viele Leute, die kennen das noch gar nicht und fangen jetzt erst damit an. Die entdecken jetzt gerade erst mal irgendwie Snapchat oder so. Fluch der Karibik. Oder Fluch der Karibik zum Beispiel. Gut, dass ihr jetzt zehn Minuten Fluch der Karibik erklärt hast und jetzt Instagram. Du bist wirklich ein Mann aus dem Jahre 2020, wie er leibt und lebt, mit seinem Fidget-Spinner in der Hand und dem The Dress-Kleid an. The Dress und dem, ey Leute, kennt ihr Herr der Ringe? Ey, ohne Scheiss, ich habe das letzte Woche gesehen, mega geil, dieser Foto. Und ist das Kleid jetzt blau-weiss oder gold-blau? Do the Harlem Shake. Gangnam Style. Do the Gangnam Style. Ja, ich bin vielleicht ein bisschen hinterher, aber ich bin up to date, ich versuche mich up to date zu halten. Sag mir mit Vans an. Ich bin, ich fand mich sehr, sehr lustig. Ich finde es ja toll, wie manchmal Personengruppen in Erscheinung treten, mit denen man davor noch nicht so viel zu tun hatte, wie zum Beispiel kleiner Shoutout jetzt mal gerade an die K-Pop Community, die gerade viel reist in der Welt. Und damit habe ich nicht gerechnet. Es gab ja diese grosse Veranstaltung von Trump, wo die K-Pop-Community ganz viele Tickets reserviert hat und dann nicht gekommen ist und dann war irgendwie niemand bei dieser Trump-Rally und alle haben gesagt, K-Pop-Szene rettet irgendwie die Demokratie in den USA. Und ich finde es so geil, wenn so auf den Plan der Geschichte plötzlich so Gruppen, die K-Pop-Community, das ist so wie wenn es irgendwie...
Ist ja auch mehr als das.
Ja, genau.
Ist ja irgendwie Punker ja auch nur auf ihre Musikrichtung reduziert werden, aber eigentlich mehr sind. Ja, ich finde es fantastisch. Ich finde es auch so gut, wenn nächstes Jahr es heißt irgendwie, die Snooker-Szene hat Trumps Wiederwahl verhindert und alle so, okay, danke. Ich habe die immer schon gemacht. Ich habe die schon geschaut, da wurde die noch auf DSF ausgestrahlt, Sonntagmorgens. Aber irgendwie so in den Geschichtsbüchern, so eine einzelne Gruppe, so irgendein Verein, so ein Truckerverein aus Baden-Württemberg. Und jetzt kommt Ian's Spiel. Genau. Die das Podcast UFO Community hat es verdient, in die Geschichtsbüchern zu landen. Ob gut, ob auf der richtigen oder der falschen Seite, ist ja erstmal egal. Das ist erstmal egal. Das ist ja erstmal zweitrangig. Das ist wirklich egal. Das ist in hundert Jahren eh alles verwischen. Da zählt es nur noch irgendwie, ob wir drin stehen oder nicht. Ja, genau. Haut mal was raus, Leute. Macht mal was. Macht mal Vorschläge. Bringt euch mal wirklich bitte ins Rampenlicht der Geschichte. Jetzt möchte ich mal, also, ich möchte, dass in der nächsten Woche einen Sprecher wählt, es muss nicht mal ein Vertreter sein, einen Sprecher wählt, das könnt ihr in der Telegram-Gruppe vielleicht machen, die übrigens, kleiner Shoutout an unsere tolle Telegram-Gruppe, mehr Nachrichten hat, mehr Nachrichten generiert in der Zeit als Attila Hildmanns Verschwörer-Gruppe, was ich ganz toll finde, da ging mir wirklich echt das Herz auf, weil ich dachte ja geil, also, dass unser Podcast irgendwie da eine coole Community hat, eine viel aktivere Community hat. Das ist doch eine tolle Welt in der Belegung, immer noch. Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt Angst habe, dass die abdriften. Immer wenn ich in den Medienlesen Telegram-Gruppe denke ich mir, oh Scheiße. Das ist genau das Gegenteil, wo ich mir denke, wenn mal irgendjemand in unserem Kontext Scheiße baut, dann wahrscheinlich die Telegram-Gruppe, die irgendwie dann, keine Ahnung, einfach abgerutscht ist politisch oder irgendwie in eine ganz merkwürdige Richtung gegangen ist.
Oder Thais nimmt ja die Kontrolle und schmeißt irgendwie die guten Leute raus und baute ihren eigenen Kult auf oder irgendwie sowas.
Kann ich mir alles vorstellen.
Kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen.
Total gut vorstellen.
Aber bislang ist es, glaube ich, noch nicht passiert.
Sie meldet sich nicht mehr auf jeden Fall.
Ich rufe sie jeden Tag an.
Was?
Sie meldet sich.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich weiß nicht, was sie macht. Keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, was junge Leute so zur Zeit treiben. Weiß ich nicht. Das weiß ich auch nicht. Fray-Lepriter hat ein bisschen auf jetzt. Gemischtes Hack hören oder so? Ja, wahrscheinlich. Twitch streamen? Ist die Star-Praktikante vielleicht? Das wäre auch gut. Jetzt rumgereicht. Wer das verrat? Wir sind doint. Wer das verrat? Wer das verrat? Weiß es gar nicht. Ja. Schon ein bisschen. Ich würde mich verraten fühlen. Nein, wir sind eine grosse Podcast-Familie. Ich finde, ihr hier... Ja, wir gehören alle zusammen. Alles gut und schön, aber ich will ja nicht Thais abgeben. Nein, aber wir gehören alle zusammen, wir sind eine grosse Familie. Es ist ja eh alles dasselbe. Ich finde, wir sollten viel näher zusammenrücken. Ja, wie gesagt, schön und gut. Aber Finger weg von Thais. Na gut, na gut. Wo waren wir gerade? Die Podcast-Ufo-Community soll was von uns reißen. Soll doch bitte einen Sprecher wählen. So, und dann hätte ich gerne drei Vorschläge. Hätten wir gerne. Und zwar die, die von euch hervorgegangen sind als die besten Vorschläge, wie die Podcast-Ufo-Community es in die Geschichtsbücher schafft. Das wäre jetzt mal so eine Aufgabe. Ja, irgendwo sowas blockieren, irgendeine Strassenblockade oder irgendwie sowas. Na sowas Kleines, was Lockeres. Im kleineren Sinne, genau. Sondern auch, wie ausführlich das Geschichtsbuch ist. Wenn es so ein sehr ausführliches, dicker Wälzer ist, deinem Nebensatz reicht ja auch. Also wenn es so ein fünfminütiges Wissen-to-go-Video ist, dann braucht ihr, glaube ich, da braucht ihr das gar nicht zu versuchen, da müsst ihr gar nicht rein. Aber so mal so eine kleine Stadt besetzen oder so. Ja, mal irgendwie so ein kleines holländisches Dorf oder so, einfach mal unter einem spontanen Putschversuch oder sowas in der Richtung. Wir können mal Holland übernehmen. Oder Luxemburg, das wird doch nicht bewacht. Die warten doch eh schon wieder, die warten doch so, wo seid ihr denn, Leute? Aber jetzt mal ganz im Ernst. Wie groß ist die Armee von Luxemburg? Sehr spezialisierte Armee. Haben die nicht so eine Maulwurfarmee, dass die so Tunnel graben können oder so? Nicht so Spezialisten? Oder ist das irgendwie so aus so Militärspielen? Welches Land könnten wir jetzt einfach mal so einnehmen? Also so ohne Scheiß? Definitiv nicht Vatikanstaat, die haben die Schweizer Garde, die sind krass. Nee, die sind nicht krass. Na ja, kommt drauf an, wenn du da in den engen Gassen kämpfst oder so, mit ihren Hellebaden. Vielleicht hat die dann ein Vorteil. Ich hab's gesagt, die sind krass, aber die sind nicht so krass, glaube ich. Ich glaube, na, weiß ich nicht genau so. Aber das ist auch nicht die Schweizer Garde, vor der wir Angst haben müssen, oder? Also bei dem Film hier mit Tom Hanks. Es ist nicht Da Vinci Code, es ist Illuminati. Ach so, oder Angels and Demons. Angels and Demons. Auch eine Trilogie, die sehr zerstört wurde nach ihrem ersten O'Kane-Film. Der erste war okay, der zweite war grauenhaft. Der dritte war auch grauenhaft. Da habe ich gar nicht mehr geguckt, was war der dritte Teil. Angels and Demons. Das ist der zweite Teil. Da kommt Meteor oder so ein Quatsch. Weiß ich gar nicht. Vielleicht gibt es auch noch einen weiteren Teil. Jedenfalls, da gibt es da die zwei Arten Schweizer Garde, und zwar einmal die Anzugtragenden, krassen Agenten. Und die Flickflackleute. Mit der P99er Tasche. Ja. Und halt die krassen Flickflackleute mit der helle Bade, wo man sagt, habt ihr euch verirrt oder wart ihr gerade noch auf so einem Lab? Ja. Und ehrlich gesagt, glaube ich, dass man gegen die eine Chance hätte. Vor allem, irgendwann sind die bestimmt wieder cool, oder? Der Glaube besitzt die halt. Also ich glaube, diese ganze historische Kleidung wird irgendwann wieder cool, auf jeden Fall. Irgendwann sind auch diese Plauschhosen und so wieder in. Ich glaube, das ist alles ein Grund. Ich meine, aber es gibt eigentlich schon Sachen, die, also so jetzt die Toga zum Beispiel, die war schon lange nicht mehr hin. So aus dem alten Rom, dass man irgendwann wieder sagt, so die Hipster fangen an, Toga zu tragen und so diese Lorbeerkränze. Aber es ist mir gerade ein Feld, wie geil das wäre eigentlich, wenn jetzt so ein Video auftauchen würde, weil wahrscheinlich hat die Schweizer Garde auch noch niemals, also in der Neuzeit wurden die ja wahrscheinlich noch nie richtig angegriffen. Niemand weiss genau, wie die kämpfen. So und jetzt, jetzt taucht dann irgendwie eine Serie, keine Ahnung, irgendwo taucht dann in dieser Serie, ich spiele gerade eine Serie, und irgendwo taucht dann so ein virales Video auf von einem Typen, der jetzt dann beschließt einfach mal, Amoklauf im Vatikan oder so was. Läuft dann da so rein, schießt auch ein paar Leute irgendwie ab, und dann kommt er auf die Schweizer Garde zu, und die benutzen da einfach so die Macht, weil es einfach... Die können aber zaubern, ja. Ja, so einen heiligen Lichtstrahlen. Ja, wie geil wäre das denn? Weil die einfach fucking und alle immer so ja, wie kämpfen die mit den helle Barten? Nein, die Antwort ist mit ihrem Glauben. Und die sind einfach so engelartige Geschöpfe und haben dann so krassen Lichtstrahlen und so können sie die Macht benutzen und es geht so viral,
dann haben die auch so einen kleinen und dann verkapseln die sich alle so und dann, ja, wie gehen die damit um, dass die Leute wissen und so weiter und dann kommt vielleicht sogar in the long run raus, dass alle gläubigen Christen,
und da wird es ein schwieriger, aber alle gläubigen Christen. Die Schweiz distanziert sich auch, sagt, wir haben eigentlich damit nie was zu tun gehabt. Das ist immer nur so ein Name, so die deutsche Bank. So zynische Leute wie wir haben natürlich gar keine Kräfte, obwohl wir natürlich die gerne hätten, weil wir halt solche Leute wie wir Star Wars Fans sind. Aber dann denkt man erst, okay, alle gläubigen Christen, die Christen sind gewonnen, Christen sind die mit den Kräften, weil Gott gibt es wirklich, wir haben alle die Kräfte, dann kommt aber heraus, dass alle anderen Religionen auch Kräfte haben, aber andere Kräfte, ja, aber die können, die Moslems können Feuer spucken, die können auch Flickflacks, aber alle können Flickflacks, oder? Ja, das kann jeder. Irgendjahr können gewöhnt werden, aber die Juden können dann irgendwie, ich weiss nicht, mega geil, haben dann andere Kräfte oder so.
Richtig hoch springen.
Richtig hoch springen, die Buddhisten können, weil sie nicht. Wow, ich glaube, noch nie wäre ein Pitch so schnell vom Schreibtisch verschwunden, wie der, jede Weltreligion hat Kräfte, aber die Christen haben die coolsten. Nein, das war nicht mein Pitch. Du hast gesagt, Juden können hoch springen, das hast du gesagt. Und die Christen können Lichtstrahlen schiessen. Das ist nicht mein Pitch. Ich fände es geil, mein Pitch wäre, alle Weltregionen haben andere Kräfte und können ebenbürtig miteinander kämpfen. Aber das ist nicht mein Pitch, das war die andere Idee. Ich fände es viel geiler, wenn er dieses Video auftaucht von einem Schweizer Gidisten, der mit einem Blitzstrahlen den Feind abwehrt. Das wäre doch mega geil. Das wäre mega gut.
Stell dir vor, würdest du sofort an Gott glauben, wenn du das Video sehen würdest?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage, das frage ich mich auch manchmal.
Aber es ist schwer zu beantworten.
Ja, ja, weil ich habe diesen Podcast, ich mache diesen Podcast über diesen Mann spuckt der Papst endlich Feuer Podcast,
wo wir jede Woche gucken, was passiert ist. Leider nein, bis jetzt jede Woche. Aber nein, ich habe diesen Podcast zu diesem Pen-and-Paper-Rollenspiel, Das Schwarze Auge. Und in der Welt von Das Schwarze Auge existieren ja wirklich die Götter und die geben ihren Geweihten Kräfte. Und wir überlegen auch immer, wie unterscheidet sich deren Verhältnis zu den Göttern, zu unserem Verhältnis, selbst von Gläubigen zu Göttern.
Also da kann dann wirklich jemanden Licht anmachen oder irgendwie in der Dunkelheit Licht erzeugen. Und wie sind die dann? Und deswegen überlege ich mir auch oft, wie gläubig die sind oder ist das für die was ganz anderes? Von daher habe ich mir tatsächlich über diese Frage schon Gedanken gemacht. Wenn jetzt wirklich jemand sagt, hey, ich heile hier die Wunde oder was auch immer und dann passiert das tatsächlich, dann müsste man an Gott glauben, man weiß es nicht genau. Ja, wahrscheinlich würdest du aber schon an glauben. Oder halt erst mal. Ja, oder halt Zauberei. Also das ist halt wenn es David Blaine macht. Gibt es dann auch so wie so einen Christian Drosten, der so einen Podcast dann darüber macht, so über dieses das erwarte ich jetzt auch mittlerweile, immer wenn irgendwie über das neue Thema will ich so einen neuen Podcast hören, von dem Experten darüber. Ja, aber das ist eigentlich ganz geil. Dann will ich so einen Theologie-Podcast hören. Ja, ja. Na ja, gibt es bestimmt auch. Also habe ich schon mal gesucht, aber die haben oft super schlechte Audioqualität. In diesen riesigen Kirchen und Katedralen immer. Immer die coolsten Gebäude, aber die schlechteste Audioqualität. Ja, ja, wirklich, die sagen, jetzt nehmen wir schon in unserem Dom auf, oder? Wir haben doch einen Dom. Ja, stimmt, ja ein Hörspiel machen oder eine Kurzgeschichte schreiben. Worse Bird hat noch eine Menge Kapazitäten offen für 2021. Wir haben wenige Projekte, allerdings kann ich vielleicht jetzt mal ankündigen, wir haben ja letzte Woche uns überlegt, die Namenskartei zu entwickeln, wo man Namen nachschlagen kann. Falls man eine coole Band hat, aber keinen Namen hat, kann man nachschlagen. Generell, für alles, wenn ihr einen Namen braucht, für ein gutes Projekt. Leute, die eine Idee haben, können sie
eintragen, andere können sie kostenlos
kaufen. Genau, Filmfigur, es ist
eine Namensbörse und
die könnt ihr jetzt besuchen, und zwar unter
namesnamesnamesnames.com
könnt ihr besuchen. Weil namesnamesnames.com
schon ausverkauft war. Richtig.
Oh, das ist übrigens
okay, ich weiß nicht,
ob du mir da folgen kannst, aber es gibt ...
Was ist das für eine arrogante Dreck?
Nein, nein, nein, ob du ... Vielleicht bist du zu dumm dafür jetzt.
Aber nee, ob du meine Faszination verstehen kannst.
Und zwar gibt es gewisse kreative Felder, die wenig Anerkennung haben, die ich aber sehr faszinierend finde.
Also die man nicht nennt, auf die niemand kommt, wo niemand sagt, das sind Genies. Zum Beispiel die Zunft der falschen Antworten bei Quizfragen Schreiber. Ja, fantastisch. Ich finde, das sind, also das ist so eine Frage, so bei Wer wird Millionär, ist ja nicht so leicht, sich da falsche Antworten zu überlegen. Die müssen auch schwieriger zu werden. Ja, schwieriger zu werden. Fragenredakteure sind fantastisch. Fantastisch, nie zählt jemand auf, man sagt immer Komponisten, Künstler, Wissenschaftler, aber nie sagt jemand Gameshow-Redakteure, die sich die falschen Antworten überlegen müssen, weil die sind ja eigentlich so, die ignoriert man, weil die tauchen ja nicht auf, aber so eine richtig gute falsche Antwort ist ein Traum. So wenn du jetzt wirklich mal überlegst, so auf die Frage, keine Ahnung, was hat der und der, warum ist diese Person berühmt? Und die Antwort ist, war die erste Person, die durch den Ärmelkanal geschwommen ist. Und jetzt gib mir die drei anderen falschen Antworten. Was sind auch Dinge, für die jemand berühmt sein könnte? Du kennst gerade das Brettspiel Nobody's Perfect oder das Lexikonspiel, wie es damals mal war, was ein fantastisches Brettspiel ist, was ich sehr gerne spiele. Wo du falsche Antworten geben musst. Genau, wo du eine Runde hast und einer liest die Frage vor und hat die richtige Antwort und die anderen drei müssen halt, kennen die richtige Antwort nicht und müssen sich eine Antwort ausdenken. Dann wird das vorgelesen mit den falschen Antworten und der richtigen Antwort. Und du kriegst Punkte, wenn du entweder die Frage richtig beantwortet hast oder richtig gefakt hast. Und ich liebe dieses Spiel, es macht mir so viel Spaß. Einmal Fragenredakteur sein mit diesem Brettspiel. Das ist ein Traum für mich. Das ist wirklich ein Traum. Ich finde das richtig fantastisch. Du kannst das Brettspiel einfach spielen, dann bist du Fragenredakteur automatisch. Grossartig. Das ist wirklich so ein Ding, wo ich manchmal denke, wow, wow. Da sind teilweise gerade so bei diesen albernen Fragen auch. Am Anfang, die lustigen Fragen. Die sind ja eher gut, es ist halt so geckig, aber auch bei den einfachen Fragen muss man manchmal mitdenken, es es gar nicht so einfach. Weil das macht eine Frage ja wirklich schwer, ist, dass die anderen Antworten auch genial sind. Ja, das stimmt. Also grossartig. Deswegen mein Shoutout, mein kreativer Shoutout diese Woche geht raus an Fragenredakteure. Mein kreativer Shoutout, das können wir mal machen, die Vergessenen, die unter den Teppich gehen, die zurückgekehrten. Ja, das ist eine eigene Rubrik, die Vergessenen? Die Vergessenen Kreativen. Vielleicht machen wir die Vergessenen insgesamt. Ah, okay. Heute dann Kreative. Bei mir wäre es die Leute, die oben bei Websites, haben ja immer oben dieses kleine Symbol. Das kleine Symbol links. Der Apfel. Links oben? Links neben der URL. Es ist stark vereinfacht. Ja, bei dem Tab meinst du, oder was? Genau. Oder auch manchmal daneben. Ich meine auch mal daneben, ich gucke mal kurz drauf. Und da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, die Künstler, die das so klein kriegen, weil das ist halt nicht nur einfach nur klein, das ist halt winzig. Und unscheiss, die haben so sechs, acht bis acht Pixel zur Verfügung. Ja, und die holen das Beste raus. Und die holen das unscheiss immer das Beste raus. Ich weiß immer grob, was es ist. Ja. Grob. Und kann sagen, ah Wikipedia oder so, das ist die Weltkugel von Wikipedia. Und irgendwie schaffen die es, obwohl die nicht so viele Mittel zur Verfügung haben, sind die mit den wenigsten Mitteln, aber dem maximalsten Output. Das ist wahrscheinlich so das, was beim Projekt als letztes gemacht wird. So, hey, mach das noch und dann zack. Oder natürlich auch bei Webseiten die Designer der 404-Seiten, wo oft noch so ein kleiner Gag ist mit einem Bär, der weint. Baustelle. Oder Baustelle oder irgendwie so ein Loch in der Wand, wo jemand durchguckt oder halt sowas. Hoppla, hier geht es nicht weiter. Wir haben die Seite verloren. Oder irgendwie sowas, was kleines Witziges. Ja, halt was kleines Witziges. Also zu den Vergessenen auf jeden Fall die 404-Seiten-Designer, auch ganz wichtig. Finde ich auch ganz, ganz toll. Gehört auch dazu. Falls ihr noch Ideen habt für die Vergessenen, schreibt an dievergessenen at names names names names names dot com. Names names names dot com. Aber ihr könnt Namen schicken an names at names names names dot com, richtig? Genau, das auf jeden Fall. Falls ihr eine Idee habt für einen coolen Namen, für einen Film, eine Serie, ein Buch, eine Autobiografie, egal was, schreibt einfach. Und die Seite sieht dann so aus. Du hast einfach sehr viele Kategorien, Bandnamen, Filme.
Ja, die Seite wird wahrscheinlich genauso aussehen wie die Podcast
UFO-Seite, weil das ist das Einzige, was ich kann.
Sie ist so schlimm.
Wie viele Reiten, es muss Unterseiten geben,
mit Namen drauf.
Ja, gucken wir es mal an,
am Wochenende.
Das wird schon. Aber was ich auch noch
sagen wollte, und zwar eine Frage,
die ich dir stellen möchte, weil ich glaube, es ist eine coole Quizfrage. Pass auf.
Wie, mit wie, ach doch, mit wie vielen O's muss man Google schreiben, damit die Website das erste Mal frei ist, also käuflich zu erwerben ist? Also mit wie vielen O's muss man das Wort Google schreiben, bis die Website das erste Mal zur freien Verfügung steht und käuflich ist? Kann sich ja täglich ändern auch, ne? Ja. Jetzt möchte ich eine Antwort von Stefan Tietze. 51. 51! Du glaubst G und dann 48 Os und dann GLE ist noch nicht vergeben, ist schon vergeben. Ja.
Na gut, ob Stefan Tietze richtig fliegt oder nicht,
das erfahrt die nächste
Woche. Nein, was?
In der nächsten Folge das Podcast-Uko,
in der Stefan vielleicht sein
Fiat Punto gewinnt oder
leider nichts gewinnt. Was?
Das sind wir jetzt nicht? Ne.
Ne, das erfahrt die nächste Woche. Aber ich finde so toll übrigens, wie cool die Musik, was die Musik von der Weltmühle ausmacht. Wirklich, ohne Scheiss, macht mal morgens diese Musik an, die man bekommt bei dieser 50-Euro-Frage. Das ist ja noch schnell. Warte, geht man ja so durch durch die 50-Euro-Frage. Stimmt, hat jede Frage ihre eigene Musik.
Ne, das ist die 50-Euro-Frage.
Dann hat jeder Joker seine eigene Musik.
Dann haben die Schnellraten am Anfang.
Dann 1000 bis 10.000 auch eine eigene Musik.
Die ist ein bisschen schneller.
Und dann gibt es so, irgendwann wird es über 64.000 wird es dann so wird es dann so
wird es dann so
mysteriös leicht und dann hat
die
da wird es dann so sehr mysteriös und dann
die Millionen-Euro-Frage hat auch eine eigene Musik
gehabt
und dann natürlich jeder Sound
also wirklich ist ein unfassbar
Vielen Dank. Da wird es dann so sehr mysteriös. Und dann die Millionen-Euro-Frage hat auch eine eigene Musik gehabt. Und dann natürlich jeder Sound. Also wirklich eine unfassbar krasse Sendung, weil die so durchperfektioniert ist.
Grossartig, aber man merkt es nicht. Ich glaube, das tut viel mit einem.
Vielleicht hört man statt dem Ocean's Eleven Soundtrack, hört vielleicht mal den Wer wird Millionär Soundtrack den ganzen Tag.
Aber die ganze Zeit guckt man so puzzled, sieht man so aus.
Grossartig, fantastisch.
Richtig schön, macht das mal.
Haut rein, wir wünschen euch eine ganz fantastische Woche.
Wünsche ich euch auch.
Viel, viel Spaß und weiterhin viel Erfolg bei dem, was ihr tut und vorhabt. Bei auch immer, was ihr macht.
Viel Erfolg bei allem, was ihr tut.
Ciao!
Lasst euch von Kritik nicht aufhalten. Macht's gut, haut rein, wir heben ab, ciao, macht's gut, ciao.
It's a war- it's a war- it's a war- it's a war-